on day one Donald Trump will be breaking
a campaign promise Donald Trump planning
to get right to work Pat after being
inaugurated after taking the entire
first weekend off trumpet said before
that after that he would not be taking
vacations he said during a 60 minutes
interview with Lesley Stahl I'm not
going to take a salary and I'm not going
to take vacations but it turns out
according to what he said to The Times
of London that his first vacation will
start immediately upon being inaugurated
here is Donald Trump's quote one of the
first orders I'm going to sign gay one
which I will consider to be monday as
opposed to friday or saturday right i
mean my day one is going to be monday
cuz i want to be signing and getting get
it mixed up with lots of celebration but
one of the first orders were going to be
signing is going to be strong borders
hey I say take a four year vacation wake
up on Tuesday November third of 2020 and
wonder what the hell happened it's sort
of like on day one of freshman economics
you show up to class after preparing all
summer and you get the syllabus and then
go home and say I'll worry about this
next week maybe I should be happy
because it's 72 extra hours before
Trump's start to undo all of the
accomplishments of the Obama
administration the entire campaign
talking about my first day going to do X
going to do i will start building the
wall we're going to repeal Obamacare
it's all of those day one promises were
so crucial to making America great again
why would you delay 72 hours before
getting started on that stuff yeah I
could see him not wanting to work on
Inauguration Day itself because there's
a big celebration and then there's the
inaugural balls after it oh yeah but the
next day even though it's a Saturday get
right to work get to it right get get to
work making America great again sad
low-energy really and as a reminder
Trump called out President Obama in 2012
here's a tweet of trumps from 2012 when
will Obama next go on vacation if he
wins the election the day after I was
getting bummed out this morning
realizing most voters don't care about
consistency and all this bogus nonsense
from Trump and then I realized maybe
that's not true after all Trump did only
get 46
percent of the vote most Americans
rejected Trump almost half Americans
didn't even vote just to make this super
super clear to you we've been hearing
from trumpets hey David he hasn't broken
any promises yet because he's not
president yet yes he said some Obamacare
provisions are very good yes he said
forget about prosecute Hillary all that
stuff but he's not president yet on day
one Trump will actually be breaking a
campaign promise and and you know now
that he's passed off the businesses to
his sons his weekends maybe will be free
to spend time with his sons not talking
about business of course they would
never ever do that hey sit out every
weekend for all I care that's two
sevenths of his presidency if he sits
out every weekend that chops off 13
months out of the four year term 22
years and 11 months of Trump presidency
is way better than four years isn't it
yeah I think it's also important to
point out that presidents have very
different working styles so while Jimmy
Carter works around the clock Reagan was
done by five but given that he's
criticized past presidents for not
working hard enough it's more uncommon
on you to actually get the job done yeah
it's not going to happen I mean it's
just as we heard from his ghostwriter of
art of the deal Tony Schwartz Trump
doesn't have the attention span to even
read a single book there's just no way
that this guy is going to be able to
hack it I look forward to tracking the
data and numbers with you for the next
four years thanks for watching this
video before you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated